on m'a demandé de vous parler d'open
innovation
j'ai bien du mal à définir déjà ce que
c'est que l'innovation
donc on va y aller doucement par contre
je suis persuadé que l'open innovation
change l'économie et va changer la
manière dont les échanges se font
baisser de vous expliquer pourquoi
alors je vais peut-être pour parler
d'innovation commencé par prendre un
exemple très simple le post-it que tout
le monde connaît qui est un exemple qui
a une histoire fameuse le post it a été
inventé par une personne qui s'appelle
steven silver qui était chercheur pour
les laboratoires de l'entreprise 3m aux
états unis il a inventé une colle qui ne
collait pas et lorsqu'il a inventé cette
colle il a eu le sentiment l'intuition
en fait que ça pouvait réellement champ
parce que ça pouvait servir à quelque
chose mais il savait pas quoi
donc il a commencé à faire le tour de la
société 3m en expliquant voilà j'ai
inventé une colle qui ne colle pas ce
que vous avez des idées d'applications
parce que moi je n'en menais pas large
où il est tombé sur un collègue qui
s'appelait art frei qui lui a dit écoute
moi j'ai un problème je vais à la messe
tous les dimanches et j'ai des marque
pages et les marque-pages tombe sans
arrêt il me semble que tu as cole
pourrait être intéressante pour fixer
les marque pages sans que ça abîme en
ligne et tous les deux en fait ont
proposé cette idée là l'on développé et
ça a donné
le post it qui aujourd'hui évidemment
quelque chose qui est totalement utile à
tout le monde
magnifique exemple d'innovation qui me
permet en fait de noter une définition
un essai de définition de ce qu'est
d'innovation il y en a plus de 40 en
fait on a recensé plus de 40
l'innovation c'est mettre en oeuvre des
idées nouvelles qui produisent de la
valeur pour des utilisateurs donc mots
clés mises en oeuvre idées nouvelles et
production de valeur alors sur cet
exemple je voudrais donner un autre
exemple qui est lui un exemple d'open
innovation
l'entreprise netflix l'entreprise
américaine que vous connaissez tous qui
à l'époque en 2006 2008
produisez envoyer des dvd à des gens
pour qu'ils puissent les regarder
netflix en 2006 se dit il faut
absolument qu'on améliore notre
algorithme de recommandations
algorithmes de recommandations c'est
permettre de savoir quel est le prochain
film qui pourrait être intéressant pour
un utilisateur de netflix
vous avez aimé chantons sous la pluie
vous aimerez la langue par exemple vous
avez aimé avenger 4 vous aimerez avec
dur ça netflix au lieu de restreindre le
problème à ses propres chercheurs en
disant il faut améliorer notre
algorithme or de recommandation ils ont
fait exactement l'inversé ils vont dire
faut surtout pas que ce soit quelqu'un
entreprises qui améliore ses algorithmes
on va aller demander au monde entier
d'améliorer notre algorithme de
recommandations et donc il poste un
challenge sur internet
en dix ans on offre un million de
dollars à toute personne ou tout groupe
qui va améliorer la performance de notre
algorithme actuel de recommandations 1
million de dollars
lorsqu'il poste ce challenge sur
internet
un jour plus tard il ya déjà quelqu'un
qui a un algorithme de performances
supérieures
une semaine après et déjà trois groupes
qui ont trouvé des solutions meilleures
et du coup netflix va continuer
d'entretenir ce challenge pendant plus
d'un an et à l'issue donc des deux ans
pendant lesquels de challenge a été
posté ils ont reçu plus de 40 mille
réponses qui proviennent de 140 pays à
travers le monde avec des performances
nettement supérieures à celles que
netflix saveurs danse est un exemple
emblématique d'open innovation dans la
mesure où au lieu de faire comme 3m de
se reposer sur des solutions et des
idées interne à l'entreprise netflix pas
délibérément cherché des idées à
l'extérieur et des solutions à
l'extérieur de l'entreprise donc
la mise en oeuvre de ces dites de ses
idées nouvelles
elle vient de l'extérieur et donc par
exemple on parle de maintenant de
crowdsourcing donc c'est aller chercher
des idées auprès de la foule
et puis naturellement aujourd'hui
comment est ce qu'on va chercher des
idées à l'extérieur on va beaucoup faire
appel aux réseaux sociaux et donc toutes
les technologies qui se développe autour
des réseaux sociaux pour aller essayer
de comprendre quel est le contenu à
l'intérieur de ces réseaux sociaux faire
des analyses de tendances faire des
analyses de données faire des analyses
de sentiments autour des réseaux sociaux
sur des technologies qui se développe
pour intégrer des nouvelles idées
d'innovation pour les entreprises
passées pour les idées maintenant la
mise en oeuvre c'est pas un autre aspect
qui est aussi fondamentale m alors qu'on
s'a je vais prendre un autre exemple il
ya l'exemple pour la mise en oeuvre de
l'open source
l'open source est une idée qui n'est pas
nouvelle c'est une idée en fait qui
s'est développée au début des années 80
quelqu'un qui s'appelle spelman travail
et waimes haïti qui se dit çà n'est pas
normal que maintenant que le logiciel et
le matériel commencent à se dissocier ce
n'est pas normal que le logiciel qui est
de la création intellectuelle
appartiennent à quelques sociétés
microsoft à l'époque qui est une société
en plein en plein boom et donc stoneman
dit il faut absolument trouver un moyen
de faire en sorte de mutualiser ses
ressources nouvelles que sont les
logiciels et donc il crée le pas sur
l'histoire qui a pris un certain temps à
se développer mais il crée il est à
l'origine en fait du monde de l'open
source
l'open source c'est quoi ces du logiciel
qu'on peut utiliser librement à
condition une condition absolument
fondamental qui est que si on lui si on
l'améliorent à ce moment là on a
l'obligation de le remettre à
disposition d'autres utilisateurs et
d'autres développeurs ça c'est des
années 80
élément clé aujourd'hui de mise en
oeuvre de toute innovation le logiciel
il ya d'autres éléments que je pourrais
passer quelques secondes sont quelques
autres éléments clés de mise en oeuvre
d'innovation un autre élément clé si la
connaissance de manière globale pas
uniquement du logiciel ça peut être tout
ça peut être de la science a peut être
des comportements utilisateurs ça peut
être tout un tas de choses
il ya un mouvement qui se développe dix
ans après l'open source qui se développe
dans les années 90 qui s'appelle le mot
le mouvement de l'open access l'open
access quelques qu'est ce que c'est
c'est au départ des scientifiques qui
disent la connaissance que l'on produit
à base de nos recherches c'est une
connaissance qui doit appartenir à tout
le monde
en effet c'est une connaissance qui
souvent en fête a été financée par des
impôts il n'est pas normal que cette
reconnaissance ne soit pas diffuser le
plus largement possible au plus de monde
possible et donc ils créent ce mouvement
d' open access qui continue de se
développer aujourd'hui et qui fait qu'il
ya de plus en plus de connaissances
accessibles de manière libre un autre
élément de mise en oeuvre très important
pour le d'innovation c'est au tour des
objets matériels autour des objets
matériels
si vous vous inventez par exemple ne
s'est pas une brosse à dents connectés
ou voulait inventer un purificateur
d'eau vous allez un moment avoir besoin
de faire des prototypes de faire des
objets dont il ya quelqu'un qui est très
emblématique qui s'appelle neil
gershenfeld qui travaillent en haïti qui
a créé un laboratoire s'appelle de
laboratoire des pics anatole ce qui
finalement essaye de répliquer dans le
monde des objets ce que l'open source a
fait dans le monde du logiciel
en quoi est-ce que ce que les beats
permettent au niveau de l'open source
les atomes pourrait également le
permettre au niveau des objets du monde
réel c'est à lui qu'on doit l'idée le
concept de fab lab
les fab lab utilise des technologies
nouvelles comme par exemple la
fabrication additive mais plein d'autres
pleins pleins d'autres technologies
nouvelles qui permettent de mettre des
ressources qui sont mutualisés de
fabrication de prototypage et qui vont
permettre de créer des objets à partir
de connaissances et à partir d'éléments
qu'on va emprunter à droite à gauche
comme on le fait pour du logiciel open
source
et puis il ya deux éléments fondamentaux
encore je n'ai pas mentionné pour la
mise en oeuvre un élément fondamental
c'est l'argent en général quand on
innove un moment donné on a besoin
d'argent bien aujourd'hui grâce à
internet il ya des nouvelles manières de
lever de l'argent qu'ils ont été
inventés des plateformes comme kiss kiss
bang bang ou comme comme d'autres qui
permettent pour un projet qui peut être
un projet technologie qui peut être un
projet d'entreprise mais qui peut être
aussi un projet artistique un projet
artistique de simplement faire appel à
la foule pour avoir de l'argent et donc
la foule peut donner un euro
cent mille euros en fonction des moyens
en fonction du projet et pas seulement
de l'argent un peu aussi donné des idées
peut aussi donner du feedback sur une
expérience d'utilisateur peut donner à
des conseils et donc c'est une manière
de faire appel à des ressources
partagées pour pouvoir implémenter un
projet le dernier élément de mise en
oeuvre qui nous paraît fondamental c'est
l'humain c'est évidemment on peut pas
innover seul on a besoin pour sa
d'innover avec des personnes et donc
autour de ça il ya aussi des nouvelles
pratiques
ils sont mises en oeuvre et qui sont en
train de se développer notamment des
plateformes qui vont permettre de
trouver des gens une plateforme parmi
d'autres s'appelle freelancer j'ai
choisi celle là une raison bien
spécifiques
c'est qu'elle utilise ce mot will answer
on parle aujourd'hui de freelens
économique
dit que l'économie est en train de se
transformer que le monde du travail est
en train de se transformer et que de
plus en plus de gens aujourd'hui travail
en tant que auto-entrepreneurs en tant
que freelance heures on dit que en 2020
50 % des américains travaillent 50 %
d'entre eux auront au moins un job en
filant donc c'est un phénomène qui est
en train de se développer de manière
considérable donc toutes ces nouvelles
tous ces nouveaux phénomènes qui se
décline dans la société dans laquelle on
vit
ils ont une influence considérable
autour de l'innovation
ça veut dire qu'ils d'ovations c'est
toujours la même chose pour elle fait
appel à des ressources qui sont
totalement nouvelles des ressources tout
à fait nouvelle pour générer des
nouvelles idées des ressources
totalement nouvelle pour mettre en
oeuvre ses idées avec tout un tas de
nouvelles et de poèmes technique de
nouvelles ressources qui se développe à
travers le monde
alors tout ça ça peut sembler un petit
peu foutoir ça peut sembler un peu
difficile à appréhender
donc je voudrais essayer de clarifier un
petit peu la source de tous a essayé de
d'identifier quatre idées qui sont
finalement commune à tous ces phénomènes
qui sont en train de se produire
simultanément
la première idée c'est que on n'est plus
dans un monde qui doit résonner globale
ou local on est dans un monde doit
résonner avec les deux dimensions
locales et globales
les gens aujourd'hui qui parle de
protectionnisme ou les gens qui parlent
aujourd'hui de mondialisation
à mon sens n'ont rien compris ce sont
les deux qui sont en train de se
produire aujourd'hui il faut aujourd'hui
être capable de réseauter global et
local
il est tout à fait possible que par
exemple quand on fait de la peine
l'impression 3d on le fasse localement
avec des sources qui sont locales et
puis on va aller chercher un design à
l'autre bout du monde si le design à
l'autre bout du monde est intéressant
la deuxième idée forte c'est que tout
c'est tous ces phénomènes font appels de
plus en plus à ce qu'on appelle
l'intelligence collective
la somme des intelligences de chacun des
individus est nettement supérieur
finalement lorsqu'elle est mutualisé
lorsqu'elle est mise en commun c'est
parfaitement évident dans le cas de
l'open source
ça deviendra progressivement le cas dans
l'open hardware et dans la notion de fab
lab
la troisième idée forte autour de ça
c'est que il ya un incontournable
aujourd'hui et il faut savoir maîtriser
des nouveaux éléments de langage vos
éléments de connaissance que sont d'une
part les technologies d'information et
de la communication et d'autre part je
voudrais vraiment insister là dessus
la science des données comment les
données aujourd'hui sont disponibles
comment les traiter
comment les agrégés comment les analytes
et comment les visualiser comment
interagir avec ces données ça devient un
élément de savoir absolument fondamental
pour aujourd'hui tout étudiant ou toute
personne qui veut continuer de se
développer dans ce dans ce monde
j'ajouterai une autre ressource qui à
mon avis est indispensable c'est
l'anglais aujourd'hui dé facto c'est la
langue universelle je suis tout à fait
pour la défense du français mais aussi
apprendre à devenir bilingues
l'angle est devenu une ressource
universel et puis le dernier élément que
je voudrais mentionner c'est ce que l'on
appelle les communs les communs c'est
une notion en fait
ancien extrêmement ancienne et qui est
en train de redevenir d'actualité qu'est
ce qu'un commun dans l'exemple d'un
village dans lequel coule dans lequel
coule une rivière une rivière c'est un
commun
c'est un bien commun qui n'appartient à
personne et qui appartient à tout le
monde et qui est important pour tout le
monde et toutes ces ressources qui sont
en train de se développer se repose en
grande partie en immense partie sur des
communs le commun que constitue par
exemple open source le commun que
pourrait constituer demain les design de
tous les objets qu'on pourrait fabriquer
en apprend d'impression 3d etc
le commun qui sont les compétences qu'on
utilise lorsqu'on fait appel à des
freelancer donc c'est commun sont en
train de se développer son entente sont
en train de devenir une source
inépuisable peut-être ou peut-être pas
de l'innovation de demain donc il faut
les entretenir il faut les les alimenter
et donc ça m'amène à mon dernier point
qui est que la façon dont on innove fait
qu'on puise aujourd'hui sur des
ressources nouvelles qui sont des
ressources collectives
il va savoir qu'il va falloir savoir
entretenir et développer et pour
terminer je voudrais faire référence
puisque ça tout ça se situe dans un
monde économique devrait faire référence
à quelqu'un vous connaissez tous karl
marx qui a décrit dans une formule
extrêmement lapidaire comment fonctionne
l'économie capitaliste
un schéma qui l'a appelé à m un
l'économie capitaliste c'est au lieu
d'utiliser l'argent pour échanger des
marchandises ont fait linverse on prend
de l'argent ont créé des marchandises et
on en retire encore plus d'argent c'est
l'accumulation du capital
c'est ce qu'a décrit marx dans ses
ouvrages
il ya aujourd'hui on est en train de
rentrer dans un nouveau monde dans un
nouveau monde économique qu'on peut
appeler économie solidaire qu'on peut
appeler économie partager qu'on peut
appeler de tout un tas de manières
l'économie du père tout père au pair à
pair
cette nouvelle économie elle reste à
inventer mais elle s'invente aujourd'hui
c'est aujourd'hui que l'open innovation
et tous ces courants que j'ai montré
sont en train de se développer
et c'est à nous c'est à vous d'inventer
cette économie qui sera peut-être un mix
de l'ancienne et de cette économie là
mais c'est une économie nouvelle qu'il
faut absolument comprendre
merci
[Applaudissements]